Oh rejects i'm greg johns so we're going
to be doing a review of the Suicide
Squad extended edition but before we go
into that I want to tell you a few
things about today's sponsor Reuters TV
that's right there's a lot going on in
the world right now and with so many
different outlets and forms of
communication it can be a little
overwhelming trying to stay informed and
up-to-date with what's going on in
today's world man that's where reuter CV
comes in Reuters TV is a new app that
will design a custom video news
broadcast for you it's tailored to your
needs and your in your schedule on the
spot on the spot just tell the app how
much time you have and Reuters TV will
assemble the day's top stories for you
from around the world the videos work
online and offline so once your video is
assembled you can take it with you
wherever you want to go authentic
unfiltered news in a sleek modern format
so you can stay up-to-date and make your
own decisions about this great big
chaotic world of ours you can download
the free app today for iphone and for
android by clicking our special link in
the box below that's app dot Reuters TV
/ the real reject it's a lot to remember
to remember but I remembered it
so we took the time today to watch The
Suicide Squad extended edition Warner
Brothers sent that over to us to review
and that'll probably be the last time
they send over something to me after
what I have to say in this video about
the movie this is second time i watched
it first time watching the extended cut
first few minutes I was like you know
what maybe this isn't as bad as I
remembered it being you know like I
remember to being like a fun mess yeah I
remember being fun it's and still
watching it today I'm like it's like
it's definitely not a boring movie it's
definitely not boring and that's that's
at least one great credit you can give
the film will Smith I think he does a
great job sure he was just will smith
and you whatever he does a great job is
dead shot yeah Viola Davis is Amanda
Waller she does a really good job as
well everything else is kind of a flip
flops between good and what is going on
you know every time you go back and
rewatch your movie usually things get a
little more clear and things smooth out
you kind of catch some of the stuff that
you missed and I was fully expecting
that to happen with this and as the
movie got going like it does like I felt
myself feeling that sense of fun early
on like I started enjoying myself and
then it all becomes kind of a blur yeah
I know it's weird it's like I still
enjoyed it this time but it didn't come
together more yeah it kind of came
together Wes the film was clearly shot
so much stuff and then they tried
piecing all the pieces together in the
editing room and try making something
linear and cohesive throughout because
one thing I could really feel early on
with the film was like one of the
biggest flaws is this phone just doesn't
know how to blend multiple genres
together well every time they cut to
another suicide squad member it's a
different genre and I get what they're
doing like like when they do like
Ocean's eleven and they introduce the
team and they they cut to their
backstories or whatever but they're shot
lit captured and totally so different
from each other Deadshot's background
with his daughter than the weird like my
everything so montage throughout well
see that I I think that's cool though
like that that's the thing is I get why
that's a mess and I and I still think it
is but part way through the character
intros at the beginning when they're
when they're at least introducing all of
the major suicide
squad characters like some of those
scenes I started to get into the groove
of that where I was like okay like the
the June moon like sequence is all shot
like a cookie like a you know imposing
sort of horror movie and like they
switch like that and in the moments
where I feel like the movie intended to
do that it works like there's some
moments or it works and there's others
were the biggest does I'm all for John
reply Singh and I don't mind when you
shift John Roos when you're telling back
stories and such it just felt like a lot
of it didn't doesn't look like it's at
all from the same movie so I think there
are movies where you could do genre
shifts and genre splicing and it works
great the problem with Suicide Squad is
it all felt like different movies the
first like half hour of the film things
don't start smoothing out a little bit
until they finally land into that
whatever that city is called again I
just don't have the many abandoned is of
the DCE yeah when they land at sea then
things are smoothing out a little bit
but before everything leading up to that
moment is kind of chaotic and all over
the place and it's like there's so much
of the setup is where a lot of my
problems come in a lot of the music
choices are sometimes really cool and a
lot of the times it seems like the scene
is just not good enough like they're not
confident enough in the scene doing a
good job so we're gonna throw in this
song that's gonna try to this song will
make you feel like this is cool but the
scene itself is not as cool as the song
is making you feel like it is like when
they threw an M&M without me song every
facet of this movie has that kind of
5050 thing for me rewatching this half
the time on this viewing the movie felt
like I was watching one complete movie
that then had parts removed and then
they just filled those parts with a
bunch of random scenes yeah so like
there are moments and especially in the
extended cut that we just watched the
moments were it's the Suicide Squad
together and it's their plot that stuff
actually kind of feels like it's in one
movie and even the way it's captured
even just the quality of the images and
stuff like that fits together in a way
that feels like it's in one movie and
then there's all this other stuff you've
got these neon Joker scenes over here
and then you've got these like really CG
enchantress scenes over here and you've
got like these Amanda Waller like
boardroom scenes over here and like you
have so many different ideas of the core
terms of this world and none of them
establish rules ever and that's what
makes the the tone shifting jarring and
that's what makes the plots still
unclear even though you catch everything
like it's easy for things that feel
unclear because everything's is kind of
rocketing forward at this steady pace
and never stopping to go but what what
are the rules and what's it all about
because that's the big problem for me
going back because there's still lots of
fun stuff the designs are cool and there
are moments everybody in this movie has
a moment for me where they work where I
get it even jared leto who this time I i
liked less than the first time they're
even moments of his where I'm like this
could be great and there are others
where I'm like this is really bad and
you know the whole movie does that for
me so yeah with the music it's like
there are certain songs that it just
feels like after a while like someone's
on a playlist like it yeah I kind of
felt like I was watching this movie with
a friend who didn't turn the radio down
this movie's kind of like having
somebody point your head in many
directions and they're all cool but you
kind of just want to ease into it no
that's what I meant by how a lot of it
just doesn't blend well to get yeah I
know it does it's too fast it's to
scatter shot its way to all over the
place I really felt like this movie
would have been better if they cut out a
lot of scenes and just let other scenes
play out yeah rewatching this the best
scene in the movie to me is still the
scene while they're all talking to each
other at the bar i was thinking like i
paused the movie for a second because i
was like i think this would have been a
great like I don't know was like
prologue or you know they like ta a
party later in the plot yeah like where
they show us team that's gonna occur
later in the movie and if they took that
bar scene cut out like maybe one or two
lines it gave away too much plot yeah
with El Diablo if you like see if you
hear him monologue the story instead of
showing the flashback right after the
moment when Harley Quinn says croc is
like he's ugly on the outside too yeah
he says I'm beautiful they have a little
laugh then I thought they could have
like cut no I want to get started back I
would have cut a little later than you
but I'm on the same way of like I just
don't think I would have want to see
joel kinnaman's character and so because
I wanted it to be like I thought it
would have added the effect of should we
trust this guy you know cuz we have is
the audience is thinking he's gonna dick
over dead Shaw regardless but that's my
little how I thought it could have
worked a little better well yeah that's
the thing it for me watch I don't know
what it is
this movie but both times and especially
the second time I've watched it the
whole time you're kind of going I know
it can make this better like yeah is it
cuz it they have everything they need I
feel like even more than Batman V
Superman digs that one kind of had
everything it needed but this one really
this was just overstuffed this film has
a very oh yeah it's over stuff and then
like sometimes it shows you that it is
the movie you wanted and then sometimes
it's just not and and the thing is this
time the big problem for me is
enchantress and that's why I started to
wonder about like that started
distracting me from the movie because
nothing about the way this movie sets up
suggests to me that this is a good idea
for them to go fight her and this is
supposed to happen after Batman V
Superman it's like week we know they're
better people for the job who clearly
come and dress the sky portal that is
destroying the seams come apart you know
and that's a bummer cuz I think it is
really fun and like there are moments
that are just cool and when the movie
just chills out enjoys itself or you
know actually what's the Suicide Squad
be together for a minute like those
moments come to life you know and they
make you like him still you know you
know oh you know one thing that just
kept sticking out to me it was like man
I just really don't get how aunt most of
these guys like the only one that seemed
like when necessary person to take on
like a case like evil Superman came yeah
cuz the whole concept knows we need to
assemble a team that could take on a
Superman type those are a whole ordeal
was like we got lucky that Superman was
good i'm thinking like bullets don't do
[ __ ] Santoso Deadshot's nothing and then
you got these hardly complain and i'm
like why is harley quinn even considered
for the Suicide Squad what the [ __ ] is
she done that is possibly made her like
she could be a great member of the
suicides but she's just an unhinged
crazy woman like was a baseball bat and
like it makes no sense for her to be
there Captain Boomerang see me literally
troilus character out of this movie yeah
he's like it's weird cuz jak Courtney
does a great job in the role but he's so
pointless in this movie el Diablo and
enchantress seemed like the only two
reasonable ones I'm like yeah send them
in to take on superhuman because they're
super human you make sense doing this
with the extended edition did
a few more scenes at croc I did notice
that and I did like that that on it
because before when I saw the original
cut I was I was like I just didn't see
the point of croc being there and so I
had to swim underneath and put the bomb
there but watching this version I'm like
I did kind of care about croc a little
more I did like him a little bit more
because we just got a few more scenes
with him yes sometimes more is actually
less like I'm conflicted about the one
very specific I think it's like the most
talked-about deleted scene of the movie
is when Harley Quinn you're just so much
I don't get about Harley Quinn and when
I watched this movie I'm like yeah
Margot Robbie is a great job bringing
the animated care heard a lot still
though I'm like why can she fight why
can she do all these crazy gymnastic
stuff and then the scene where she like
is on the motorcycle then she starts
with rising motorized I'm like a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] hero I'm like wait a minute
you're not even Harley Quinn yeah you're
still the doctor at this one Jews are
still like your kind of there but not
kind of it but you haven't like trained
innocent combatants like you're a doctor
this doesn't make sense that if all the
exposition on lines this movie has
unlike just be me one expositional line
of like yeah she studied gymnastics when
she was 12 or something something to
make me go she's a doctor I don't get
how she could do any of these action
heroes though yeah how one of a baseball
bat why are you necessary to see well
yeah the only thing I can figure is it
you know if you get your brain
electrocuted craziness is a superpower
yeah so she can believe she'd do this
stuff so she says like all right I could
get on board with that I guess but
that's knows i'm still watching it like
now there's no sense to me a died she's
even here for this cuz this movie
doesn't Everest at like it doesn't take
the time to establish that stuff this
movie is in our it's in a hurry all the
time and sometimes being in a hurry
school and sometimes it's not and it
never actually stops to address a
problem in the room ok my problem with
that scene that actually happens is jer
lodos whole performance in that scene
that just kind of got on my nerves
something told me after hearing all this
[ __ ] he did on set something kind of
made me feel like he took it too
seriously to the point where he didn't
have any freedom to really just let
loose
like in a natural organic way I felt
like he was 22 in his head about all
this stuff and it kind of shows like I
could be wrong either way it just feels
plan every movement every every line of
dialogue he has every every movement he
does feels very planned it doesn't feel
organic or improviser natural it's it
seems forced again like they're half the
time it seems really forced to me in
half the time you know there are moments
in there that I think are really cool
and in those moments I think yeah this
version the Joker like I know some
people can't get over the look and vibe
I don't know like he's villain I think
it's kind of leave that Zeph style is
kind of a neat way to do that it just
feels like a two-dimensional but I feel
like yet like the impression areas lack
of death yeah yeah cuz the impression I
get from the way at least I was covered
and I didn't read tons about it but I
read about like ah you've sent someone a
dead pig and condoms and stuff like that
yeah I'm Scott is you did all this crazy
I'm gonna call your old girl on second I
don't know I feel like maybe he got to
who to into the crazies out of it and
not really into making it a real
character yeah like in terms of genre
splicing his story felt like a different
film like not just not just because of
like his jizz yogurt or is really not
essential to the whole movie other than
that it's like the way they shoot his
story feels like a different movie it
feels like it's just out of a different
tone and style entirely one thing I
thought would have helped this movie is
if we felt like we were watching this
from some type of perspective cuz right
now I just feel like we were watching
everything go on you know how like for
like the first like hour of the movie
they key to keep like not informing the
Suicide Squad of what's going on but
we're in the audience and like we know
most of what's going on there's a crazy
metahuman that enchantress unleash cuz
the camera and everything told us
already so so we're not an even in the
shoes of the Suicide Squad plan this
does that's what I mean we're not in the
perspective of anyone and I felt like it
would have been interesting if they
liked ease some of that stuff but didn't
make you put her to us what was going on
and we were in the perspective of the
Suicide Squad from things well I still
don't completely grasp the switcheroo
where they're really going to save a man
to Waller
yeah because the movie kind of starts
off when when enchantresses brother
shows [ __ ] up the subway they say
Senate Task Force X they only send an
enchantress enchantress you know leaves
does her thing and then they're like
what everyone else so they start
assembling the rest of the game and then
they're bringing them over and we think
they're gonna take out like oh they're
going there take out a chantress and the
subway do and then they have actually
rescuing a Manowar I was like one when
did they change their plans this is
rescue what was that establish day when
did she even get into this city is it
supposed to be a twist oh like what I
could establish and why is it in this
building that's giving Harley like joker
harley origin flat yeah cuz i couldn't
tell that was posed to be in like the
same there were just big circular things
which was just seeing things that room
like when she sees the bite of
motorcycle on the ground she just from
that the motorcycle waiting Oh back to
that say no I get back to SC what I
wanted to say it was that even though I
didn't like that she knows my first
words were i'm glad that was left out of
the movie which one on the highway that
was when she does the motorcycles yeah
but then when it came to the seam in the
ACE chemical plant when Harley jumps
into the toxic waste and he jumps in
after I thought this scene that the
flashback that I didn't like I thought
because that flashback was there it
actually made that seem more effective
yeah because we had a scene where
Joker's just like oh man I'm trying to
get the [ __ ] away from you he's leave me
alone I can't stand you I could see how
from first perspective he is like okay
she's gone finally she killed herself
good yeah but then he's like no I can't
let her die cuz he really does love her
you know so I thought that made that
effect that extra beat yeah that made
that effective even though i don't like
that scene it still made that seem
better yeah oh yeah and i would have
preferred that in the original cut if
anything i enjoyed both cuts to this
movie in a way like i did enjoy watching
this but re watching it now especially
here like nothing they added in really
changed the experience of watching it
for me and I know like Batman vs
Superman and they're like they added a
bunch of stuff in and from what I've
been told they at least clarified the
plot more the only benefit I got out of
the stuff they had it back in was I like
to the Suicide Squad better yeah like
when they had those scenes of them all
kind of circulating in and out and
talking to each other like though
they had that scene in there they
extended you know they're all going to
each other sandwich we're planning on
breaking out of here and Deadshot's kind
of running this yeah but then so it made
more sense when Deadshot was like wait
right here what the hell is going on
okay but real quick what is the point of
turning these human beings who are under
her control into these weird likes power
rangers reliable monster because it's
like if they seem to have nothing
special other than like I think he liked
leaked through something at one point
and when he went Harley was in the
elevator yeah but I'm like you guys seem
like very weak actually when you're in
this form it's like if Harley Quinn can
easily just knock off your whole skull
with a baseball bat you could kill a
human being with a baseball bat for sure
with one blow but it's rare where you
see you guys have to go flying off of
just a baseball bat and I'm thinking
like these creatures seem more fragile
and easier to penetrate yeah easier to
break and they set up that scene even by
Sigma oh don't engage them like we can
yeah Mike what's so funny about them
under then there's there in quantity you
know like half the suicides about like
these guys really good at shooting and
hitting stuff and have it a little crazy
sin like it can't be impossible because
they're not more strapped up than the
military guys are they just have better
you know I felt like the best scene in
this movie you know despite except for
the bar scene I really did like that
seem like we're dead shot we're dead
shot gets to use weapons again as you
see his love for weapons the way all
that plays out before that the
interaction but when he's [ __ ] with
everyone and then the scene he has with
joel kinnaman afterwards like that that
whole scene i thought was really well
done and that was ad they didn't talk
any different in the extended edition
but i'm like that's a great team right
there every scene like a lot of the
scenes in this movie to me and then
maybe this relates felt like there was
some incentive to get them out in the
leased lines possible and then the few
scenes where it feels like it's not
about the lease lines possible the movie
actually starts to come to life and it
actually establishes something that
resembles a rhythm that's more than just
a través a quick because because a lot
of this movie becomes it feels like a
trailer because you're showing a lot of
cool images they're changing really fast
and they all seem vaguely intense and
hurried but only a few of them actually
slowed down enough to like moving
Pia and I couldn't help but find even
more nitpick flaws when I was watching
this movie like I was thinking one you
know like Enchantress the human version
June I don't really care about Joel
Kinnaman getting her back because I
don't know June at all yeah other than
whenever I see her as June she's talking
about she doesn't want to be in
chantress and starts crying and that's
about it that's all I know about
especially doesn't like being a chance
that people only get so much time to be
their own character and she has to be
too so like those characters just once
evil and one doesn't want yeah and
that's all we know but you point out
something to like when enchantress
starts to like vanish and like take [ __ ]
she does it so easily all she had to do
is wait for two people to follow oh yeah
did you or thing and then unleash she'll
like even when she got her brothers
whatever the little statue of her
brother was like why was it just in like
Amanda Waller's closet on the shelf yeah
why wasn't it like locked away and some
like secret like her heart is in like a
briefcase and it's so like why not put
the dish dinner her brother's thing not
on the closet somewhere it's just some
item that we don't think has any
potential for anything actually lock it
away in some way it seems like that that
bother me when like the prison guard of
jade what's his name Ike Barinholtz Ike
Barinholtz League I like Ike Barinholtz
I even like his scenes in this movie but
I kind of annoyed me when he when Harley
Quinn was you know had the thing over
and she was beyond the wheelchair that
he's like I got something from Joker for
you i'm gonna talk super loud about this
and give you something pretty large and
colorful and no one's gonna suspect the
thing that happens right now I'm gonna
call after you by your first name yeah
as though I want this information cuz
it's important to be a out loud there's
a lot that starts to feel like
afterthoughts because to me like this
time watching it I felt it just struck
me I felt like I was watching something
based on a detailed treatment cuz it's
about as much as we get out of any
scenes so like some details are just too
big and you're like how did nobody
notice well yeah like how did this not
get refined and that's why like lots of
things start to feel like afterthought
kind of everything to do with
Enchantress in this movie just kind of
feels like an afterthought they got
money
all over it because she's doing this
like Wiggly cg thing and all of a sudden
the movie shifts cuz like when they're
climbing the tower in some of those
scenes and like building bits are on
fire and stuff like some of those scenes
kind of reminded me of like terminator 2
for some reason yes like that same
Tambor and then they cut to these other
scenes like with enchantress and it just
feels like really quick and very
expensive they don't really seem to have
much personality beyond it all these
things start to feel like they were
crammed in for some reason you know like
and that's why I can't help but wonder
if this movie got like severely recut
cuz I know they said like there's so
much Joker that they haven't when they
put the footage back into this movie
some people complain that that much more
generic not that what we got made us
feel any better about it but still it's
like why would you have all that footage
for a character that for this movie that
we just saw feels like you could cut the
Joker out and I wouldn't care my problem
with this movie was the Suicide Squad
sounds cool and all just not to take on
you know like save the whole [ __ ]
planet yeah like I feel like suicide
squad would have been better to take on
like smaller villains like more evil
that's not about destroying the planet
but like you know assemble them for
something still works like they feel a
need to help out and that's your
opportunity and that's why I'm Ellie
personal and smaller yeah and that's why
i got like David Ayer is theoretically
good for movie like this I thought what
do you be doing it's like dealing with
these guys dealing with other battery
guys not dealing with like cliche CGI
bad guys yeah and it's like you have
this all powerful enchantress and her
all-powerful brother who are just gonna
destroy the world cuz people don't
worship them no more and then you have
these guys who are you know only
equipped to do very physical world stuff
it's like the Joker makes perfect sense
that's why you need a team with a big
guy and a crack shot and a crazy guy at
his early credit yeah that makes sense
you go after him with these guys and
then you're like okay I know why they
would need the SWAT because this is you
know the SWAT team arguably can't do
this they need the worst of the worst to
go get the crime Prince of Gotham like
that would make and easily more on the
level story with much more do their
rules you know the prom with this film
as I know some people say this with like
Marvel films of like why did the
Avengers step in when this [ __ ] was
going to why a vendor step in this movie
has flashbacks with Batman
it and the flash in here and they have
access to communicate to these guys for
something that is out of the hands of
you know like someone like El Diablo for
example il Cielo and need other people
to work with at least like why don't you
call in the flash or Batman when you can
clearly communicate with them yeah for
something this crazy yeah it's like the
flash I mean you have to get your mail
or your team for the mid credit scene is
a post that she has all the Justice
League information of everyone and
that's the things I do i how call on
these guys to save the planet and that's
what becomes frustrating about this
movie because the second time around and
even with all the added stuff it never
seemed like any of that got really taken
into account the second time watching
this movie especially like that stuff
really started to stick out it's like
why waste your time with Captain
Boomerang you sent the flash to get him
you sent Batman to get a shot the only
reason you would do that is if you were
fighting things that were below there
like this is clearly something you need
those guys to handle oh you know yeah
and you can't ignore that while you're
watching this so you start to wonder
about just why this is all happening and
so much of the movie sort of starts to
come apart because like I feel like
someone might justify it saying like a
man a wall or wanted to make sure there
were people she can control and because
they're criminals and they could like
plant them and stuff they can control
them not for this mission what happens
mission though you got lucky and put
that aside for a second Ango the world
is about to be destroyed because i
really wonder what this movie was
supposed to be cuz cuz like when we were
watching it i started to get Inklings
how it could all fit together with most
of the stuff that they have and if you
look at it like what David Ayer did or
at least what the Suicide Squad is like
it's kinda like an army battalion you've
got like your fire guy your demolitions
guy your sniper guy it's a very
down-to-earth kind of villain movie
these are criminals you know like mega
medicaments her not many I mean the last
thing I want to comment on that I had a
more of a problem with the second time i
watch this move yeah was the scene when
Joker shows up in the helicopter and
Harley Quinn goes and jumps on ok
several issues with that see at first
you
sleep that finally makes it clear like
oh that's the whole point of Joker's
storyline is he's gonna take Harley away
but then my first feeling was Harley
doesn't seem that necessary to do this
mission yeah like I know she's the one
who played dumb and then cut open the
Enchantress's you know chest and took
out her heart I was like they were
planning I don't think they thought
Harley at hi there's nothing leading to
that mower we're thinking about the
mission at hand where I was like this is
a bummer Harley's essential to finish
this I can't do this without her well
that's the problem with villain in this
movie is that every every upper hand
they get over her is like out of a
really lucky break like everyone's got a
lucky chance and like thank goodness
they were able to get this you know and
then even when will Smith I'm even
though when a man of Walter's telling
Will Smith to like shoot her yeah I'll
give you a contract your freedom and all
this stuff i'm thinking like you don't
need Deadshot right now yeah you got a
bunch of other soldiers who could easily
take her out she's like she's she's
doing aerial dance it like she's just
messing around the only why you're on
the rope just like theoretically you
should tell them cuz you hell are slive
of your men to try to shoot I'm sure one
of them will get her and I don't know
why anybody keeps trying to take a
chopper and this yeah I'll Jane shot
down yeah nobody nobody cares about
crashing helicopter newer building but
it's like I can't stand the finale
though man like when they all become
like when El Diablo's are spinning
family lines even Harley Quinn's I my
friend like that kind of [ __ ] I'm like
nothing nothing has led to you guys
there's nothing that justifies those dot
that blind dialogue they're like it's a
level of emotion or something you guys
haven't been put in situation's where
we'd really looked out for each other
like the yeah all being forced into this
and you guys have all been in survival
mode this whole time but not like we
need a band together they haven't had a
single moment like that and they make
them out to be heat like total soup like
major good guys in the end and you spent
so much of the film trying to make us
feel like they're bad guys and I'm like
man you have it too though yeah like I
don't know you know you're all kind the
only do bad things it seems like too bad
people
are people that you know like it does
none of them do anything dastardly ever
and they all seem to have like some kind
of moral compass yeah exactly they all
just want to be free or something I
didn't get the whole thing about like
Will Smith like I know what love is it
and I know they tried to play that I
forgot they trying to say that note in
the Anakin were he like struggles
decided to his daughter and I just never
once believed that this guy clearly
cares about his daughter about your
daughter [ __ ] don't say that
shits aren't like that lining yeah the
line is like men like me after many
people like okay you're saying this with
a genuine smile and your relax and
connecting with a girl about not knowing
love and it's like this whole concept of
you is the revolved around you wanting
to be back with your daughter I feel
like there's a version of that line that
could work somehow if you like drafted
at four more times but it's like yeah
it's directly in contrast with every way
he behaved like even the people he kills
he establishes like I don't kill women
or children like I kind of heard that
code these are all pretty bad guys to
begin it's like even in regular people
morality at least some a couple folks me
like I get it yeah you gonna make money
and he's the one to keep saying we're
the bad guys and I'm like I don't Killer
Croc seems like he just wants to chill
out in the sewer and eat people that's
that's bad Captain Boomerang seems like
he should just be in a regular jail
exactly el Diablo is in kind of regular
I didn't see lady just be longer yeah
well no they can't del Diablo in that
water tank he should be on that space
prison from guardians of the galaxy like
he should be in a place like that and
just like everyone's a kooky character
he has a boomerang that like after a
certain point in the movie where I
couldn't tell if this was ever the
original intent like his boomerang can
fly and take videos of stuff randomly
rejoins the Suicide Squad I still AM
kind of bugged by that it's what he left
the took it's a real bummer because Jai
Courtney is great anyway he's so not
essential to the movie and it's like
it's it's the one time I've been really
enthused about him since like Jack
Reacher it's really strange how he's one
of the great performances of the movie
yeah you're like totally unessential to
anything that goes on in this film
though nothing feels essential past a
certain point Deadshot keeps the story
going cuz you like Deadshot
I you know I like Will Smith I like his
dead shot you know I he's cool the movie
gives me some time to get to know but
like everybody else and at a certain
point feels completely expendable and
nobody feels at peril cuz like they
never pay off al Amanda Waller gets out
of that one yeah and they never pay off
you know why Harley just kind of like I
guess I'll just rejoin these people I
suddenly like you know like all these
things happen you just have no idea why
at a certain point like everything feels
like it happens because it's hard to
watch that again now for you DC fans out
there who've just watch this whole video
you're probably gonna say stuff like you
guys don't know what you're talking
about and then you're gonna find like
one or two things out of like the 40
things we talked about and then try to
harp on us about it if you can respond
and debunk all the things we said then
I'll take your comment into
consideration at the end of the day look
I enjoy Suicide Squad I enjoyed things
about it I think there's some moments of
greatness in it but I also think it's
good still kind of a mess Reuters TV
subscribe to the real rejects genres
reason to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
he's a social media manager of Facebook
of the bloom house and the real rejects
and shout out to Cesar Romero I love
your dressing and your pizza